hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
klassiker unter den torten und zu machen
wir eine schwarzwälder kirschtorte auf
kiki art nämlich ohne alkohol und ohne
gelatine und die schmidt unglaublich
lecker denn es ist ein klassiker ich
kenne wirklich niemanden der sie nicht
mag für dieses rezept benötigen wir
meinen schoko biscuit ich habe euch dazu
ein separates video gemacht weil das
unwichtig von mir ist und den habe ich
bereits zweimal durchgeschnitten also
habe ich drei schöne dünne böden und
jetzt zeige ich euch die restlichen
zutaten
wir benötigen sauerkirschen aus dem glas
die habe ich hier abtropfen lassen dann
habe ich ein teil des saftes in einen
topf gegeben und einen anderen teil hier
zum trinken in eine separate schale
hier habe ich noch speisestärke die
könnt ihr gerne durch vanillepudding
pulver ersetzen außerdem zucker und
etwas zimt für die creme benötigen wir
kalte schlagsahne etwas vanille zucker
zucker sahne fest und für die deko beleg
herrschen und zartbitterschokolade oder
kuvertüre so dann fangen wir mal an also
ich habe jetzt die sonne zurück in den
kühlschrank gegeben damit wir auch
richtig eisig kalt ist es ist ganz
wichtig und wir kümmern uns um die
kirschen und dafür habe ich jetzt den
saft der kirschen habe ich ja bereits in
einem topf das habe ich gerade schon
gesagt da gehen hier die speisestärke
zimt und zucker rein und dann wird das
mit dem schneebesen gut verrührt bis
keine klümpchen mehr da sind
[Musik]
und falls ihr kein fan seit dann lasst
es einfach weg oder ersetzt es durch
vanillezucker ich persönlich mache das
so im sommer dem frühling nämlich gern
vanillezucker und wenn ich die torte
dann im winter- oder herbst zubereitet
dann nehme ich gerne zum beispiel dass
es gut zusammenpasst jetzt das ganze
klümpchen frei der herd wird
eingeschaltet und unter ständigem rühren
einmal ausgekocht dann merkt er dass es
schön einlegt
[Musik]
so jetzt ist es ganz so richtig schön
eingedeckt an der stelle den schneebesen
nicht mehr weiter verwenden weil sonst
machen wozu unsere kirchen kaputt
schwierig die kirchen mit dazu und hebt
sich schön unter am besten mit einem
kochlöffel oder einem normalen löffel so
das ist jetzt fertig und es riecht schon
richtig lecker und ich gebe es jetzt
kurz an die seite räumen hier alles
wegräumen meine böden und dann zeige ich
euch nicht weiter geht so solange die
kirchen noch warm sind müssen wir etwas
zügig arbeiten ich habe mir jetzt hier
zwei bühnen schon mal hingelegt den
dritten habe ich da hinten die brauchen
wir erst später und ich habe euch ja
anfangs gesagt dass sie etwas von dem
tier schafft zur seite legt denn damit
trinken wir jetzt die böden also nehme
ich jetzt mein erster boden und gibt ein
bisschen kirschsaft obendrauf
[Musik]
so und dadurch werden die böden noch mal
richtig schön saftig denn weich sind sie
ja schon und jetzt gehen wir die hälfte
der kirchen drauf und verteilen das in
der mitte aber auch nicht ganz bis zum
rand
[Musik]
es ist nämlich wichtig dass hier am rand
so ungefähr 2 cm abstand lassen damit es
später auch optisch richtig gut aussieht
wenn die sonne drauf kommt so den ersten
boden habe ich erledigt das gleiche
machen wir jetzt auch noch mit dem
zweiten
[Musik]
sobald ihr das ganze dann bestrichen
habt machen wir jetzt die sahne creme
fertig wie wichtig ist nur dass das
wirklich komplett auskühlen ihr wisst ja
wenn sagen in verbindung mit warmen
lebensmittel kommt es nicht so gut und
schmilzt das ganze deshalb seid euch
sicher dass das ganze komplett
ausgekühlt ist und dann könnt ihr die
sonne drauf warten aber zuerst zeige ich
euch wie wir die creme herstellen
die sonnencreme superschnell gemacht
denn dafür benötigen wir nur unsere
kalte schlagsahne direkt aus dem
kühlschrank wichtig ist auch dass die
schüssel nicht warm ist und der
schneebesen aus letztlich waren
denn das führt dazu dass die sache nicht
richtig aufschlägt und dann wundert ihr
euch dass die geringe es hat immer alles
schön kalt dass man kann auch nichts
schief gehen
das gehen sie einmal in die schüssel die
sahne und schlag das richtig schön steif
geben nach und nach zur vanille zucker
und sahne fest mit hinein
[Musik]
sobald die sonne dann steif ist die
sahne creme auch schon fertig und ich
zeige euch jetzt nur noch wie ihr die
torte zusammenstellt
[Musik]
für das fertigstellen der torte jetzt
einfach den ersten boden mit den kirchen
auf die wunsch servierplatten lediglich
eine drehbare und dann gebt ihr euch
einen tortenring drumherum dann könnt
ihr das ganze besser füllen so
einmaligen verschließen und jetzt ein
drittel der seine zehn drauf geben und
schön verstreichen
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann die erste sahne schicht
schön glatt verstrichen habt gibt die
den zweiten boden mit den kirchen drauf
das ist so ein bisschen heikel weil der
wirklich schön weich ist und dann müsst
einfach ganz vorsichtig und langsam
vorgehen wo aber wird schon schiefgehen
[Musik]
so hat ganz gut geklappt und jetzt
wieder zwei drittel der saane darauf
verstreichen
[Musik]
so die sandschicht ist jetzt auch schön
glatt verstrichen und als nächstes kommt
nur noch der letzte boden ins spiel
hatte ich hier die ganze zeit unter
seiner haube
damit ihr uns auch nicht austrocknen und
er hat jetzt so eine richtig klappte
oberfläche weil das ist der boden von
unserem biscuit gewesen dann hat ihr
sohn richtig schön gerade abschluss das
werde ich jetzt auch noch mal kurz
umdrehen trinken und dann auf die torte
geben
[Musik]
zu den letzten tortenboden habe ich
nochmal ganz leicht angedrückt und jetzt
gebe ich noch meinen torten retter oben
drauf dann mich auch von oben nicht
austrocknen und gäbe denn jetzt für eine
stunde in den kühlschrank man kann
dieses schöne fest werden und dann wird
ihr nur noch dekoriert so die kühl zeit
ist jetzt oben und jetzt nämlich erstmal
den tortenring ab und dann können wir
die torte fertig dekoriert
[Musik]
und die saale war übrigens die ganze
zeit über im kühlschrank das ist ganz
wichtig dass sie schon fest ist und ich
habe mir hier einen teil auch schon mal
in einen spritzbeutel geben mit seiner
schönen rosen tolle vorne dran damit ich
sie gleich schön dekorieren kann aber
jetzt wird zuallererst die torte
rundherum mit der sahne eingestrichen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte komplett verstrichen
und als nächstes kümmern wir uns um
unsere schokolade entweder nimmt der
tafel schokolade oder zartbitter
kuvertüre jack ouvertüre immer da
deshalb habe ich jetzt kuvertüre
genommen steht natürlich auch vollmilch
und die restliche kuvertüre die wird
jetzt hierzu schokoraspeln verarbeitet
ihr könnt sie natürlich auch fertig
kaufen aber die sind ein bisschen größer
und das sieht optisch einfach viel
schöner aus
[Musik]
und als nächstes verteilen sie die
kleinen süßen schokoraspeln an den rand
der torte ihr könnt dafür gerne eure
teil karte nehmen oder ihr könnt auf
diesem zitronen trick verwenden das
einfach eine halbe zitrone nimmt und das
auftritt ganz wie ihr möchtet
[Musik]
und nachdem die seiten richtig schön mit
den schokoraspeln eingearbeitet wurden
machen wir auch die oberfläche damit
voll so dass die ganze torte richtig
schön bedeckt ist als nächstes kommt
nämlich unsere seele noch mal ins spiel
wie ich vorhin zur seite gelegt habe und
um die seiner top war jetzt auf zu
spritzen müssen wir uns hier ein
bisschen platz verschaffen
ich mache jetzt die zwölf stücke daraus
das könnte natürlich schauen ob 14 oder
16 ich finde 12 sind genau angemessen
dann nehme ich mir mit einem kleinen
löffel einfach hier so ein bisschen was
weg und werde dann die sahne töpfe auf
spritzt man anschließend die beleg hier
schon obendrauf geben
[Musik]
und zum abschluss nur noch die leckeren
schoko späne oben drauf und dann ist die
schwarzwälder kirschtorte fertig ihr
könntet sie sofort servieren gerne aber
auch noch mal in den kühlschrank gehen
nämlich alles richtig schön fest wird
ansonsten könnt ihr die torte auch gerne
am vorabend schon zu bereiten die frage
wo komme ich ganz oft gestellt generell
so torten die könnte ich immer am
vorabend zu bereiten und sahnetorten
halten sich drei tage lang gekühlt ich
freue mich wenn ich mir fotos zusendet
mit dem hashtag die skizzen auf
instagram ansonsten folgt uns dort gerne
dann bekommt ihr auch immer so ein
bisschen private einblicke und previews
was bald online kommt ich freue mich
wenn ihr mir ein dörfchen nach oben gibt
mir tolles feedback dallas und main
kanal kostenlos abonniert damit ihr auch
nichts mehr verpasst und dann sage ich
bis zum nächsten mal aufliegers kitchen
tschüss
[Musik]